we're asked to shade 20% of the square
below and before doing that let's just
even think about what percent means so
let me just rewrite it 20% is equal to
20 I'm just writing it out as a word 20%
which literally means 20% let me break
it out which is the same thing as 20 per
cent and if you are familiar with the
word century you might already know that
this cent comes from the latin for the
word hundred so this literally means
this literally means you can take cent
and that literally means a hundred so
this is the same thing as 20 per hundred
twenty per hundred twenty percent means
you're really going to weed if we want
to shade 20 percent that means we want
to shade if you break up the square into
100 pieces we want to shade 20 of them
20 per hundred so how many squares have
they drawn here so there's let's see if
we go horizontally right here we have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten squares if we go vertically we
have one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten so this is a 10 by 10
square so it has 100 squares here so if
we want to shade this or another way to
say it is that this larger square though
I guess that's the square that they're
talking about this larger square is
broken up into 100 smaller squares so
it's already broken up into the 100 so
if we want to shade 20 percent of that
we need to shade 20 of every hundred
squares that it is broken into so then
this will just literally shade in 20
squares so let me let me just do one so
if I just do one square just like that I
have just shaded one per hundred of the
squares 100 out of 100 would be the
whole I've shaved one of them this would
be that one square by itself would be
one percent of the entire square if I
were to shade another one if I were
shade that and that then those two
combined that's 2 percent of the entire
square it's literally 2
per hundred we're a hundred would be the
entire square so if we wanted to do 20
we do one two three four actually if we
shave this if we should not shave if we
shade this entire row that will be ten
percent right one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten and then we
want to do 20 so that'll be one more row
so I can shade in this whole other row
right here and then I would have shaded
in 20 of 100 squares or another way of
thinking about if you take this larger
square divide it into 100 equal pieces
I've shaded in 100 or I've shaded in 20
per hundred or 20 percent of the entire
square hopefully that the entire larger
square hopefully that makes sense